Hello Freak bitches.
It just doesn't seem like a huge product
gets everybody gets their phone ruined
by pouring a drink on it.
Like that's the number one
reason phones get ruined.
I would say cracked screens.
Toilet.
I will take cracked.
Screens are probably higher than water,
but they're both high.
Speaking of cracked screens,
cracked screens.
Almost universal.
Right.
Does everybody get a cracked screen?
I've never had one,
but I've had to move a Turd
to get my phone out of.
Out of the toilet.
Did you kill the phone or the phone?
Survive.
How long was it in English?
It literally like I got up and then it
fell in the toilet and I was like God put
my hand through her and grabbed it,
pulled it out and then.
And then just write it off.
Put it in a bag of right now.
It didn't even wash his hands as far.
Now I did the shaky thing and
the good enough hairdryer.
Oh really?
What you should do if that happens
is 24 hours in a bag of rice.
Yeah,
it'll.
It'll pull away moisture.
What I usually end up just doing,
then having something stopped working
and then take it to the APP or call the
apple store and they will
send you one with that.
Apple's great with that.
Here's the weird thing though.
They put,
or at least they used to.
I don't know anymore.
I used to do some repairs on these things,
crack them open and get crazy like that,
but they used to put little litmus
paper in there that would show.
Got Wet.
It would turn red.
He used to be in the headphone Jack.
I don't know.
They probably still do it.
Still do it,
but that.
But if you call they don't.
There's no way from
their check when I say,
here's a question,
when you say if you drop
something in the toilet,
drop upon the children,
should you shut it off and
throw it in the bag of rice?
Oh,
should you leave time to turns itself off,
but it.
Yeah.
If you.
If it's still on,
turn it,
turn it off.
Shut it off.
So shut it off.
Throw it in the bag of rice.
Yeah.
What I usually do is just
suck the water out of it,
but,
but I wasn't going to do
it with the poop ones.
Why not?
Because when you suck it off,
if you look at your iphone,
like there's the top part where the.
That's where your ear usually goes,
but there's water that's in there.
So you stuck that and you're
like pretty much sucking earwax.
It's gross.
I never,
I never thought of talking on my phone.
Ever been to that.
You mean like I go really hard many times.
Have you done this?
Probably like five times.
So where's your fault when
you're going that you're getting earwax.
If you look,
if you look,
there's like a little grill that's right
there and if you look really close you
could actually see their shit in there.
I was thinking about the Jack itself,
but you have to suck all of them.
There's the bottom one that you suck.
You suck like power.
Does that work?
Can you really suck the water out?
Will really help.
That's what I'll always do.
You mean getting,
getting water away from it is
going to be a positive thing,
but
the guy on the phone,
customer service here,
listen,
I've been sucking on my phones that cool.
I'm just saying in the
most polite way possible.
I wouldn't recommend it.
No.
Well,
and that's a problem because we
have capitalized and privatized the
education system to hear such a degree.
I mean if you.
If you got a degree in
Australia where rights,
Macquarie University or Sydney University
or University of New South Wales,
it's an Mba.
One of us.
Google's is exactly same as an mba
at any one of our schools here.
You know you had not only does an MBA
matter that all of a sudden and it has to
be from the right school,
so an Mba from Harvard or an Ivy
League school is trump's and mba from
university of San Diego or something like
that and that shouldn't be the way and
affect what that does.
It still keeps propelling that plutocracy
because there was a study done that at
least for every student at Harvard,
a student and have.
It has at least one parent earning
at least for $100,000 per year.
So we're still,
you know,
with the capitalization of everything.
We're,
we're forming a system where we have,
you know,
the very wealthy at the top and we have
everybody's struggling in the bottom
that the elite ism involved in education
is really fascinating to me today.
Especially because there's so
much access to information,
so many books,
so much online,
so much to read and just you can get so
much access to information that would,
you know,
a long time ago.
The difference between going to Harvard
and go into San Diego state was pretty
gigantic.
But what with what you
have access to today,
the average person has access to the
exact same information that they're
teaching at any school anywhere.
But I had a conversation with a friend
of mine and he was wrong about something
and I brought up this woman who had.
She had went to the
University of Mississippi,
but she went there and this was her major.
Like this thing that
we were talking about.
And he goes,
well,
this guy went to Yale.
But he didn't even go to jail for that.
He went to jail for
something else and he's 80.
Okay.
So he went to Yale and
like the 19 sixties,
who knows what the fuck they
were teaching back then.
Like what are you talking about man,
you know,
like,
but the eye,
his first initial reaction was,
look,
she went to the University of Mississippi,
he went to Yale.
I'm like,
oh,
that's hilarious.
But that is the way we
think in this country
it is.
And also not only is it the way we think,
but you know,
these kids that are going
to mit or harvard or Yale,
well it's the networks I take with them.
So when the jobs are about,
you know,
the only growth area that we have in
this country as a technology jokes.
But that's such an inshallah job
market where only the networks,
the alumni from these prestigious schools
get to really apply from all the kids
working at Google.
They all went to these fancy schools
that could be afforded by the wealthy
parents.
Collin quit a long time
ago reminded me many,
many years.
My first,
like on an opiod,
anthony,
I was dating a British girl
and she was a real pervert,
like I drove a Saturn back then I still
lived in Jersey and I used to fucking
park outside of Dangerfield
and she would blow me.
I would trap.
She liked,
been to trap her head under my
steering wheel and she would go like,
I want you to bite me,
I want you to bite me.
Like she would repeat this mantra
of me biting her on her back.
She liked to be bitten and brutalized
by her back and she was like,
I want you to make me suck it,
and then I would hold her head under
the wheel and she'll be trapped under my
Saturday steering wheel
and fucking she would suck my dick
and lick my balls and whatever.
Good kid.
He was a good girl.
Yeah.
Her name is ruth.
She was a really cool girl.
Ruth.
Yeah.
Good five and talked to her in 15 years,
but she was a great guy.
Mr. Terribly.
I think you went back across the pond.
Hello?
As they say.
And what was the point of
the story of the Colon?
She was really loud when I ate her pussy.
Really super loud.
And it was,
she say,
I don't remember.
Just moaning and groaning.
One of those things.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Whatever it was.
I
beat my pussy like it's Manchester United,
but I can't.
It was a really low and puts
you a sloppy fucking wet.
Like it was legit.
Like I knew she wasn't putting on a
show because her pussy was sloppy,
but I was going to eat her
pussy on the air be a year.
This is before I was I get everyday and
be a good quality and your pussy on the
air and I was going to do that.
And Collin Quinn stopped me and he goes,
you know,
and he goes,
you can do that.
You could put them in.
You're a comic.
You got to say funny shit.
You don't want to be that
guy that does wacky things.
And I'm like,
I never forgot that.
He was almost telling me,
don't be a stunt boy.
You gotta say it funny.
You got to sit there and be funny verbally
and I maybe in that case he was right
because I wasn't the gun,
the Wacko who call up at
eight pussy on the air.
It's like I have to be able to
be funny in my delivery and say,
and I was like,
eh.
That was kind of a good point.
Looking back in hindsight,
I probably should have eaten or pussy
on the going to be a very funny clip.